[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Dieses Video möchte ich heute nutzen,
um ein Grundrezept mit euch zu teilen, nämlich den Eierlikörkuchen.
Der Eierlikörkuchen muss nicht zwingend alkoholisch sein.
Man kann nämlich Eierlikör auch alkoholfrei zubereiten.
Das habe ich euch schon einmal auf meinem Kanal gezeigt.
Also könnt ihr den trotzdem gerne zubereiten.
Dieser Teig ist im Prinzip ein Grundrezept
auch für saftige Motivtorten z. B.
Statt Eierlikör, also statt dieser Flüssigkeit, könnt ihr im Prinzip auch
andere Flüssigkeiten nehmen: Saft, Buttermilch, Kaffee, Cappuccino.
Also im Prinzip könnt ihr damit den Geschmack des Kuchens steuern.
Jetzt, weil es gerade Frühjahr ist
und weil Eierlikörkuchen sehr oft im Frühjahr gegessen wird,
gerade zu Ostern, wie gesagt, heute ein Grundrezept.
Ich werde das Ganze in einer Gugelhupfform backen,
aber ihr könnt auch eine Springform nehmen mit diesem
Röhrenboden, heißt er, glaube ich.
Das ist nämlich auch so eine Marmorkuchenform.
Ihr könnt darauf einen Kastenkuchen backen,
ihr könnt auch einen runden Tortenring nehmen
und, wie gesagt, einzelne Böden daraus backen
oder ihr könnt auch so eine Osterlammform nehmen
oder andere Backformen und den Teig da hineinfüllen.
Ich hatte auch so einen ähnlichen Teig
schon einmal als Grundrezept gemacht.
Das war der saftige Boden für Motivtorten.
Aber wie gesagt, heute noch einmal in dieser Eierlikörversion.
Ich verwende dafür 5 Eier, 180g Puderzucker, 1 Prise Salz,
250g Eierlikör, 125g Sonnenblumenöl und jeweils 150g Mehl und Stärke
und ein Päckchen Backpulver - das sind 3 TL.
Den Ofen könnt ihr jetzt schon einmal auf 165°C
Ober-/Unterhitze vorheizen.
Am besten gelingt der Kuchen, wenn die Eier nicht kühlschrankkalt sind,
sondern wenn sie schon ein bisschen warm sind.
Oh mein Gott!
Warte! Salz rein und Puderzucker.
JOSH: Hol es schnell!
SALLY: Oh je! [Lacht] Fast vergessen.
Wie konnte ich das nur vergessen? [Laut der Anstrengung]
1 TL Vanilleextrakt.
[Laut der Anstrengung] Das reicht für diesen Monat.
Okay.
Stell dir vor, was für eine Wertanlage. [Sally und Josh lachen]
So eine 8.000€-Flasche.
Okay. Die Eierzuckermasse wird jetzt etwa 5-10 Minuten cremig verrührt.
[Musik und Küchenmaschine]
So sieht die Masse jetzt wunderbar aus.
Da kommen jetzt beide Flüssigkeiten hinein.
[Musik]
Den brauche ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Die Zutaten kann ich jetzt vermischen und dazusieben.
Ich gebe übrigens immer in meinem Blog und in der App
das Backpulver in TL an und damit meine ich - ich zeige es euch -
immer den Messlöffel.
Er hat ein einheitliches Maß. Es ist immer ein gestrichener TL.
und ein Päckchen Backpulver sind exakt 3 TL.
Deswegen gebe ich es in TL an,
damit ihr auch die Rezepte hoch- und runterrechnen könnt,
ohne dass ihr dann irgendwie eine 3/4 Packung Backpulver habt,
weil das abzumessen ist dann schwieriger als eben mit TL umzurechnen.
Das ist der Gedanke.
[Musik]
Jetzt noch kurz vorsichtig einrühren.
Das könnt ihr jetzt im Prinzip auch mit der Küchenmaschine
oder mit dem Handrührgerät machen, aber bei ganz niedriger Stufe.
Perfekt!
Ihr seht auch, ich schlage die Schneebesen nie am Schüsselrand ab,
denn dann würde ich ja die ganze Luft, die ich hineingerührt habe,
wieder rausschlagen.
Jetzt nehmt ihr euch eure Backform nach Wahl,
dann leicht einfetten, entweder mit Butter oder Backtrennspray,
und den Teig schön hineinfüllen.
[Musik]
Je nach Backform braucht es etwa eine Stunde,
manchmal auch nur 50 Minuten oder auch ein bisschen länger.
Ich glaube, ich mache jetzt den gleichen Teig noch in kleinerer Menge
und werde noch ein Osterlämmchen backen.
[Backofen] Weil es eine recht hohe Backform ist,
relativ weit unten backen, damit der Kuchen oben nicht so braun wird.
[Musik]
Die Backformen habe ich jetzt hier etwa 20 Minuten abkühlen lassen.
Hier hat sich ein kleiner Hubbel gebildet. Den nehme ich weg,
damit ich den Kuchen gut rausstürzen kann.
Ich lasse sie immer gerne so ein bisschen ankühlen
und lasse sie aber noch in der Form,
damit der Kuchen an sich einfach nicht kaputtgeht.
Nach so etwa 20 Minuten löst er sich dann auch wunderbar heraus.
Tada! Da muss man einfach geduldig sein.
Wenn man den nämlich zu früh herauslöst,
ist mir auch schon ganz oft passiert,
dann bleibt der Kuchen zur Hälfte in der Form hängen,
weil er eben noch nicht fest genug ist.
Also wirklich immer so 20 Minuten abwarten.
Hier ist es sogar so - den werde ich hier oben begradigen,
damit das Lämmchen gut steht.
Ich backe zum ersten Mal ein Lämmchen - ein Osterlamm.
Ich hatte noch nie so eine Form,
aber ich denke, man muss es - ja.
Der ist unten ein bisschen ausgelaufen.
Ich habe ein Backpapier daruntergelegt.
Okay, ich bin gespannt.
[Musik]
Ich lass jetzt abkühlen und dann können wir es mit
süßem Schnee bestreuen und servieren.
[Musik]
Komm, wir zeigen dem Josh noch unsere Sonne.
SARAH: Okay. Du musst von oben.
SALLY: Ah ja.
SALLY: Ja.
SARAH: Können wir?
[Stimmt zu]
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Das war die Sonne.
SARAH: Du hast die kleinen Mini-Streifen und ich bin gelb.
SALLY: Ja. Ich hatte vorhin noch so senfgelbe Ohrringe,
aber ich fand's dann zu arg.
JOSH: Können wir einfach probieren?
SALLY: Zu viel gelb.
SARAH: Wenn ich neben dir stehe.
SALLY: Ja.
JOSH: Hallo? Können wir einfach probieren?
SARAH: Die ist auch gelb.
JOSH: Hey Sonne!
SALLY: Juhu. Ihr dürft probieren.
Ich hab den Kuchen jetzt mit süßem Schnee bestreut.
Ihr könnt auch Puderzucker nehmen, aber der schmilzt an der Oberfläche
und süßer Schnee bleibt auf der Oberfläche.
JOSH: Aaaah!
SALLY: Auch bei Krapfen, auch bei Berlinern, ...
SARAH: Außer er (der Kuchen) ist schon abgekühlt.
SALLY: ... auch bei warmen Gebäck.
Nein, dann schmilzt Puderzucker auch.
SARAH: Echt? Auch wenn er abgekühlt ist?
JOSH: Warum nimmt man dann Puderzucker überhaupt?
SALLY: Weil man es einfach nicht anders kannte.
[Josh und Sarah lachen]
Man macht es drauf.
JOSH: Dass dich das noch niemand gefragt hat.
SARAH: Puderzucker!
SALLY: Das ist für den Haushalt immer so.
Man hat Puderzucker drauf und sofort gegessen.
Der schmilzt ja nicht sofort, aber wenn du jetzt den Kuchen abdeckst
über Nacht, dann zieht da ja die Feuchtigkeit
und dann schmilzt der Puderzucker, aber süßer Schnee bleibt.
JOSH: Aaaah!
SARAH: Ich brauche süßen Schnee zu Hause.
SALLY: Süßer Schnee gab es nur für Konditoreien.
JOSH: Hast du das?
SARAH: Nein.
SALLY: Nein. Das haben wir eingeführt!
SARAH: Ach!
SALLY: Das haben wir eingeführt!
JOSH: Achso!
[Sarah und Josh lachen]
Für den Haushalt.
SARAH:
JOSH: Aaaah! Okay. Kauft süßen Schnee.
SALLY: Das war so nicht geplant. Das war so nicht geplant.
SARAH: Besser als Puderzucker.
Ich wollte euch nur aufklären.
Jedenfalls ist das ein Suppenteller, Sarah, aber ist egal
SARAH: Darf man auf dem Tuch schneiden?
SALLY: Nein.
[Sally und Sarah lachen]
SARAH: Oh, danke!
JOSH: Ich will ein Stück mit süßem Schnee.
Ich mache eine Kostprobe, ob er auch wirklich standhält
gegen Puderzucker.
SALLY: Ich habe es euch einfach schon einmal in Portionen geteilt.
JOSH UND SARAH: Mmh!
SALLY: Macht man so bei Kindern.
[Sally stimmt zu]
JOSH: Voll fluffig auch.
SARAH: Es machen alle so.
[Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: So ein richtiger Sponge Cake. Oh!
JOSH: Hört man das?
[Sarah macht Quietschgeräusche und lacht]
Psst! Sei ruhig!
[Ein leises Geräusch von zusammengedrücktem Kuchen]
SALLY: Das hört man.
JOSH: Hat man schon gehört, oder?
SALLY: Ja. Und ich habe ja hier -
also ihr kennt Speisestärke gar nicht so oft aus meinen Teigrezepten,
denn Speisestärke macht den Kuchen so ein bisschen sandig,
eigentlich feinsandig-trocken, aber hier geht's, weil...
[Josh und Sarah lachen]
... viel Flüssigkeit vorhanden ist.
Was lacht ihr jetzt wieder?
JOSH: Das sagt man doch, wenn er schlecht ist, oder?
[Alle lachen]
Der ist so sandig.
SALLY: Und ich habe so relativiert.
JOSH: Ja.
Ich mache bei Biskuit z. B.
- oder bei anderen Rührkuchen mache ich auch keine Stärke rein,
denn dann wird es sandig und trocken, aber bei dem Kuchen
geht es mit der Stärke. Dann wird er so fein.
Ihr merkt es doch, oder? Die Textur ist so fein.
SARAH UND JOSH: Ja, das stimmt!
SALLY: So feinporig.
JOSH: Der ist nicht so matschig...
SALLY: Genau.
JOSH: ... luftig, sondern so fein.
SALLY: Und weil eben das Verhältnis...
JOSH UND SARAH: [lachen] sandig-luftig.
SALLY: Und weil eben das Verhältnis von Öl zu Flüssigkeit,
von Mehl und Stärke stimmt, ist er eben nicht so trocken.
SARAH: Und der süße Schnee.
JOSH: Wir haben viel gelacht, aber der ist echt wahnsinnig lecker.
SARAH: Der ist wirklich sehr, sehr gut und saftig.
SALLY: Und sehr luftig.
SARAH: Ja.
SALLY: So Sponge... Sponge Cake.
SARAH: Ein klassischer Gugelhupf.
JOSH: Der süße Schnee hält immer noch.
SALLY: Er hält immer noch. Ich sag's dir, der hält auch morgen noch.
Der wird dann im Prinzip einfach abgedeckt,
bei Raumtemperatur gelagert und dann hält er so die nächsten 3-4 Tage,
wenn er übrigbleibt.
Bei uns nicht. Bei uns ist er morgen leer.
JOSH UND SARAH: Bleibt er nicht. Ist er morgen leer.
SALLY: Bei uns ist er morgen leer.
Also backt das Rezept gerne nach, teilt euer Ergebnis gerne mit mir,
schreibt mir, ob er bei euch sandig-trocken oder sandig-gut war.
SARAH: Macht den *Ui-Ui*-Test.
SALLY: Der *Ui-Ui*-Test.
[Alle lachen]
Das Rezept gibt es wie immer auf...?
JOSH: Sallys Blog!
SARAH: Oder in der App!
SALLY: Ja. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
SARAH: Das nehme ich.
SALLY: Okay. Wollt ihr noch ein Stück?
JOSH: Das nehme ich.
[Sally lacht]
Ach komm, und ich räume auf.
JOSH: Nein, komm! Du kriegst auch ein Stück.
[Musik]